jedenfalls habt ihr direkt einfach
daneben direkt habt ihr jetzt erstmal
ins netz porten weiterer sport und wir
sehen schon hier eine pyramiden tempel
sich issendorf ja mal direkt wieder so
einen komischen tempel was in bagdad wir
sind hier tatsächlich in einem strom
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung endlich
mal wieder und zwar bin ich mal wieder
die kommentare durchgegangen wurden so
viele geile seeds gesendet außerdem eine
weiterleitung zu einer anderen sieht
vorstellung allerdings habe ich gedacht
oh mein gott meine mono brown die sich
so gott verdammt heftig hässliche alter
egal
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich stelle
euch den zieht auf jeden fall auch vor
damit ihr den findet und zwar ist es für
mich einfach der geilste sie den ich
irgendwie entdeckt habe und zwar habe
ich ja schon mal einen geilen zieht
vorgestellt wo ich meine ist der
allerbeste die ich hier gesehen habe war
es auch damals das war der wo3 spawn an
einem waren allerdings ist das hier
einfach es gibt so viel hier zu erkunden
dass es so heftig es ist einfach nur
krass und normal ups jetzt bin ich im
moment so jetzt immer hier und zwar der
cee'd ist buck einfach bock boka ich
weiß nicht große klein schreiben das
glaub ich scheiß egal ich würde trotzdem
lieber alles klein schreiben eastbourne
eigentlich relativ genau hier
beziehungsweise sohn dieser area
deswegen aber jetzt hier so einen
schnieken bieten blocking gestellt mit
so ein paar blöcken die ich dann mal
eben aus meinem toiletten wänden raus
gekraxelt haben bis der bescheid bei mir
ist alles aus diamant gebaut
in meinem schwarz fotoalben ein quatsch
jedenfalls habe direkt einfach daneben
direkt habt ihr sonst unseren zum dorf
das ist total heftig also ihr habt da
natürlich keine black swan es also keine
schmiede oder sowas aber ich habe direkt
im dorf alter das ist so krank also
direkt neben
neben dem dorf gusborn direkt hier ein
paar kühe am start direkt da hinten
sehen wir gerade sind super land
schaffen da kann man ja super brücke
darauf bauen wenn man hier in haushalt
und dann an der brücke darüber baut und
dann zu dem dort finden wie das auf
jeden fall mega chillig die sachen
verschwinden jetzt schon langsam weil
wir müssen weiter in diese richtung
fliegen beziehungsweise müssen wir erst
mal ganz kurz tier hin ich fliege schon
wieder viel zu weit leute ich habe ein
paar sachen in chat geschrieben und zwar
die ich euch zeigen möchte und schon das
sind sehr viele sachen da drin und zwar
wartet mal zunächst einmal x9 und 49 und
111 49 mit dem neuen vierte kläger nahm
49 ich glaube das ist da 49 und 111 149
moment und zwar wenn wir uns hier erst
mal unterboten
sehen wir im moment wir sind gleich da
hier ist erstmal eins klettern an der
küste sind ich so geile sachen drin
außerdem tag ist relativ klein und halt
drei schallplatten bisschen redstone und
na ja das war es auch schon hier
allerdings wenn man sich jemand bis zu
weitere unterbaut und dann so hier ca so
die breiteren rhein gilt
ich sollte mir eventuell eine fackel
holen wenn ich hier bin jedenfalls eine
fackel das ist ich schon nicht mehr
fahrbar
aber wir wollen natürlich ganze sache
nie drin lassen deswegen jetzt nicht
raus aus minute haben hier sehen wir
weiteres borner wir nehmen die sachen
wieder mit und zwar einfach ins bonner
und einfach jetzt direkt noch ins bonner
also direkt bei einander nicht mal 20
blöcke entfernt die beiden bonner hier
kann man eine super xp falle daraus
bauen wir eine supermacht falle wäre auf
jeden fall hammergeil ihr könnt übrigens
mit dem sid machen was ihr wollt und
myvideo antworten senden was man gehen
überhaupt video antworten
ich weiß nicht wie ich das gesagt habe
gehen doch wieder antworten ich weiß es
nicht ich weiß ja auch nicht leute wir
können hier jedenfalls ein bisschen
fliege ich überhaupt richtig - 370 und
minus 138
egal also wir müssen auf jeden fall so
ein bisschen in die richtung fliegen
oder sehen wir hier schon moment studie
verwüsten wüste finde ich persönlich
mittlerweile immer geiler weil da auch
mittlerweile hier sehen wir schon so ein
paar oasen drin sind und den passenden
expected extender sieht auf jeden fall
mégane eis aus und wir sehen schon hier
einen pyramid
tempel allerdings wird es in dieser
wüste dam dam k2 geben und noch ein
dörflein hier sind nicht allzu gerne
sachen drin in den tempeln in dem
anderen tempel ist auch nicht so dass
alle gäste drin das dorf wieder keine
schmiede aber dazu kommen wir gleich
noch wenn ihr jetzt erstmal hier alle
sachen mit damit wir danach jetzt ein
bisschen hier revue passieren lassen
können was wir denn so alles gefunden
haben also verrottet die fleisch und
knochen das jetzt nicht nennenswert mehr
jeder von uns hat verrottetes fleisch
und knochen an sich und auch im redstone
natürlich jeder mensch einfach deswegen
müssen wir es einfach gar nicht erwähnen
so wenn man jetzt hier einfach ein
bisschen weiter in richtung westen
fliegt
meine stimme ich habe eine nacht mit
offenem fenster gepennt und mein ganzer
halten ist im eimer
also der ist wirklich im eimer ihr seht
den staat nur welche gerade aus nur
einmal raus geholt habe also hier ist
ein dorf nicht in der nennenswert
allerdings ihr seht noch da hinten die
ihr seht ihr nicht ganz verschwommen
sowie in den tempel und dann sind wir
hier ein bisschen weiter im moment
falsche richtung hier hin da fliegt man
hier ein bisschen weiter also hört dass
sich erkältet bin ich glaube man hört
aber vor allem so von 1 tag auf anderen
das kommt wahrscheinlich welche mal dann
vom trägen lassen und t shirt wer weiß
ja aber direkt wieder so einen komischen
tempel was indes tief in bagdad clubs
wir haben natürlich auch immer noch tnt
darunter von daher dass t durfte
natürlich auch nicht vergessen
so was haben wir hier noch vor drin
jetzt also das ist die blutige sachen
aus den beiden pyramiden sind relativ
gleich von daher die nehmen sich da
nichts jetzt eine sache die ist sehr
weit weg und zwar die drei sachen wir
abgearbeitet und jetzt - 6 und 643 und
466 a643 minus 406 richtig los denn ich
denn hin
hey ich habs doch ganz andere sachen
rausgesucht
ich muss doch jedoch das richtig muss
jetzt hier hinfliegen und zwar obwohl es
gar nicht so
währenddessen kann ich mal über ein
bisschen was quatschen und zwar sieht
vorstellung allgemeinen sind ja sehr
selten gekommen weil halt die letzte
vorstellung immer so waren so stellt das
vor basta dass er gar keine arbeit
hinter also sieht vorstellung ist mit
mod reviews das was am meisten arbeit
ein
also mir bereitet weil man sich die
ganze information raussuchen muss man
muss das irgendwie vorbereiten dass man
das lustig runter rattern und man kann
natürlich einfach dahin gehen und da
hingehen und dahin gehen und dann ist
fertig 630 es wegen nutzt sich solche
intervalle zwischen verschiedenen orten
bei dem zieht auch immer dazu dass ich
mich etwas quatschen kann jeden fall
wieder viel zu weit moment im moment 643
hinzulegen
wechsel bei einem 40 mal hier und moment
deswegen kommt ein bisschen jedenfalls
ich habe damals meine serie a-team livio
sein ich habe damals mal in serie
gemacht die sind übrigens schon da eine
serie gemacht wo ich immer jeden tag ein
neues lied vorstellung gemacht habe wenn
ihr denn eine bestimmte anzahl an likes
erreicht habt deswegen schreibt einmal
ob ihr sowas wiederhaben wollte
allerdings sich jetzt erstmal hier
runter und was hier kommen wird wird
euch alle zu bumsen und zwar ich muss
ein bisschen weiter erst mal okay die
neuesten daten - prof wir sind hier
tatsächlich in einem strom von euch
erstmal street der mega stores mit dem
texture pack dieser typ der einfach mal
zwischen den stronghold machte jetzt
habe ich ihn zerstört also mégane ist
auf jeden fall direkt strongbow er dann
direkt das ende erkunden könnt war ich
muss ja auch durch und jetzt müssen wir
lange fliegen
jetzt kann ich mein thema fortsetzen und
zwar glaube ich wir müssen in die
richtung moment ich checke mal kurz ab
270 und 400 sage ich mal 272 moment
moment moment moment 270 das minus 270
und 400 400 - 400 jedoch 408 oder blöcke
kleinen ding machen und zwar wollt ihr
sowas dass ich das wieder machen also
das könnte dann so aussehen wie werde
ich das lied verstellung macher an einem
montag zum beispiel sage ich dann am
montag in der seed vorstellung wenn ihr
3000 likes erreicht 20.000 like strain l
3006 erreicht dann kommt am nächsten tag
direkt noch das lied vorstellung das sag
ich da wenn ihr 4000 bikes erreicht dann
kommt am nächsten tag alters wird macht
das heißt wir schon voll drauf da kommt
am nächsten tag knochendefekte nämlich
wie mich zwar noch eine sieht
vorstellung also ihr könnt das quasi
selbst alles immer wieder dürfen
ihr könnt es quasi selbst alles so ein
bisschen bestimmen ob ihr am nächsten
tag noch eine sieht vorstellung sehen
wollt oder liegen konnte bislang keiner
das ist eine sache die ihr selbst
bestimmen könnt ihr müsst ja nicht
leicht sagte hennig lars gabler ich will
immer nur das ihr leicht gefallen hat
und wenn das nicht gefallen hat dann
bitte auch nicht leiden weil das ist
dann auch besser weil dann sehe ich ob
es euch gefällt so dass zu machen oder
nicht und deswegen gibt einfach den
daumen hoch wenn er dafür wäre dass ich
so eine serie wieder einführe eventuell
dann bei weiss nicht wie vielen daumen
hochwertig dass da mal machen weil sie
nicht 5000 eine krähe schaffen wir das
schafft unsere community 5000 xalter
unsere community also ich weiß es nicht
ob ihr da wirklich so aktivseite ist er
das schafft können wenn man die
challenge ausmachen
jetzt legen wir erstmal bei stock und
stein bei teilzeit 0 natürlich wollt ihr
dass ich solche serie mache oder nicht
schreibt zwar eine kommentare und ja
gibt einfach daumen hoch war daran kann
man das besser sehen
das wäre auf jeden fall interessant zu
wissen weil ich hätte bock auf sowas und
dadurch dass die klausurphase noch nicht
also werde ich dann zum beispiel immer
sage 20.000 likes gräfin neue folge dann
übrigens das training das nicht ernst
machen will so nach und wenn ihr damit
ein bisschen bloßstellen
solche leute aber dazu bald ein video
flughafen real life kanal dich auch in
dem
man könnte auch einmal vorbeischauen
noch nicht gucken wo wir hier sind dann
wenn ihr das dann nicht schafft dann
hört die sicherheit auch aber mal ganz
ehrlich so dass so passiv vorstellung
für euch und zwar damit übels heftiges
fly mountains epic wartet wie heißt
dieses bio extreme hiltrup extreme hills
bei um das war gerade diese mischung aus
raps und gehen
bereits kurze zeit und zwar durch das
mal reinalter das ist mega heftig dass
sie zu abgefuckt geil aus geil oder hier
sondern dieser berg einfach perfekt
angeordnet dass es dort weiß ich ich
fange das also das sieht auf jeden fall
megastaus hier alles und auch wenn man
hier so hoch guckt was als und ihr habt
auch hier direkt eine schlucht da unten
drin
ich will letztlich rhein waal schaut
wenn ich ins wasser gehen als es dunkel
alles ist welche zurzeit also das ist
hier allgemein alles relativ dunkel ich
kenne ein paar faktoren hinsetzen dann
werdet ihr mal ein bisschen sehen wie
das hier so anders als hier
das kann man ja hoch fliegen also das
ist auf jeden fall heftige schlachten
und hier das ist besonders geil man kann
hier so rein fliegen hier so sieht der
tack tack tack tack tack tack kann
hierdurch könnten theoretisch sondern
kleine baseball fährt man diese mit boot
durch dann macht man hier den fluss noch
ein bisschen so unterirdisch dann geht
er hier noch so lange geht dann hilft
eine treppe hoch und dann hat man hier
dann sondern seine fette will ja hier so
mittendrin und dessen zombie thriller
drin die man hier oben im turm und keine
ahnung kann es sogar sachen baut auf den
server draufpacken etwas bauen
das ist so mega es ist auf jeden fall
hammergeil ihr könnt mir eine video
antwort gelegt denn ihr könnt aber
videos davon machen und dann leichte ich
dass eventuell ins geiles wenn ihr da
was geiles ausgebaut hat jetzt natürlich
nicht nur noch 15 stellen so ein scheiß
haus hin contractors teil mäßig naja
leute wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
gibt einfach den daumen hoch bei 5.000
will ich da mal sagen setzt sich mal
wieder anders sieht vorstellung serie
hier ist auch wieder so eine brücke
alter also hier gibts echt sachen zu
entdecken mensch management management
der beste sieht denn es gibt wenn ihr
also wenn eure freunde immer fragen was
das für zieht dann schickt den einfach
mein video könnte auch auf facebook und
twitter und überall teilen wo es geht
einfach und aufteilen klicken und sonst
klingt markig 5000 mal nein einmal
reicht und dann sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wiederkommen mir aussieht sind die
kommentare schreiben wenn ich dann ein
paar vorstellen soll und dann